chinese tennis star feng shui has
apparently retracted her controversial
sexual assault allegations in an
interview with western media
previously pong had alleged on social
media that she had been forced into sex
by china's former vice premier the post
was deleted and pong then disappeared
from public view for three weeks
sparking concerns for her safety
pong shui spoke to the french sports
newspaper lei keep with a chinese
olympic official in the room and said
her allegations of sexual assault
against a former official of the chinese
communist party was an enormous
misunderstanding
sexual assault she is quoted as
responding to pre-submitted questions
i never said that anyone sexually
assaulted me in any way
before her accusatory post from november
2nd was scrubbed from her verified
account on chinese social media though
screenshots were posted on twitter pong
writing that zhang li of the
all-powerful politburo standing
committee had forced her to have sex
despite her refusals she told la'keep
that she is the one who erased the post
in addition to the l'keep interview the
international olympic committee
announced monday that ioc president
thomas bach and others dined with pong
on saturday
spokesperson mark adams said the ioc
will not judge whether an investigation
on pong's initial allegations is needed
i think we need also to listen to her
and we need to for
to read what she's saying we've invited
her to come to europe uh and we will
meet her again and i think um i think we
can say that we are doing everything we
can to make sure
that the situation is as it should be
at the daily news conference adams
wouldn't say whether ioc officials
believe pong is speaking freely with
them or under duress as many experts
believe
the sports organization are doing
everything to ensure
that she
is happy
in her interview with le keep hung
echoed the chinese government saying her
quote romantic problems her private life
should not be mixed with sport and
politics
and we can speak now to journalist
fabian kretschmer in beijing for more on
the story hi fabienne um feng shui is
now saying that she never made any
allegations how does that actually fit
with the allegations that appeared on
her social media account
well not at all she doesn't doubt that
she was writing that post and in that
post there's one controversial line that
clearly said um i was at least pressured
into having sex some um media also um
translated as
i was being raped i mean we could talk
about the nuances of the translation
what fits better into the context but
the allegations were made and
now it's not really very believable that
she retracts everything she basically
says nothing to see here everything is
okay i deleted the post by myself um i
didn't disappear i was accessible all
the time that is not really in line with
the facts that are really well
documented here fabian there have been
examples of people who have been coerced
into making false public statements in
the past in china under duress could
that be what we're seeing here with feng
shui
possibly i don't want to make any
speculation but it's important to
acknowledge that those um con forced
confessions do happen to regularly
happen i also interviewed um several
victims and it's a systemic problem here
um i cannot um look into the mind of
peng schwein but
it's important also to note that she is
under pressure she is most often
followed by government officials also
when giving those interviews and um of
course it could also be that um it's her
free choice to make those statements we
don't know i mean from her um weibo
account the social media platform we
know that she's also quite patriotic and
who knows maybe she regrets um having
made those comments but that's why an
independent investigation would be quite
important to get to the ground of that
case
last question we know that she met with
the chief of the international olympic
committee thomas bach what role is the
ioc playing in getting to the bottom of
this
well thomas bach played a quite shameful
role in that already in the beginning of
the case he was basically um
helped the propaganda apparatus here to
get the message out saying that
everything is okay um he's not really
credible when it comes to make critical
statements so um yeah i think his role
is not very helpful
journalist fabian kretschmer speaking to
us there from beijing thanks for that
reporting
and we have our cw sports correspondent
jonathan crane who is following the
winter olympics for us in beijing hi
jonathan it's good to see you so what is
the ioc saying about the situation
in short not a lot but that is a story
in itself because peng schwein once
again dominated questions by western
media at the daily news briefing in
between questions from chinese media
about sporting equipment and athletic
competition now
has rode back on her allegations in this
interview with lee keep raises just more
questions about how free she is actually
to speak about her situation the irc was
asked about that in today's briefing
essentially mark adams the spokesman
said we're a sporting organization and
he said it's not for us or you meaning
the media to judge her situation now uh
thomas bach in his press conference last
week said that the ioc would support
pangshui if she decided to pursue her
allegations in the courts i wanted to
find out how that actually would work in
practice given her situation and this is
that exchange
what conversations have there been with
officials here in beijing about a
possible investigation
and does the ioc think that is actually
possible for pong to do can she make
that demand without fear of any
repercussion thank you
i'm not sure we're able as a sports
organization to make that call i think
the president was right in saying it
shouldn't be for us to judge whether
there should be an investigation or not
you've seen the words um which in the
interview which she gave to la keep i
think it was an hour and more interview
um yes yesterday or the day before
whenever it was
which was published this morning
i think we need also to listen to her
and we need to for
to read what she's saying um as we've
also discussed we've been in contact
with her we remain in contact with her
we've met her in person we've invited
her to come to europe and we will meet
her again and i think um i think we can
say that we are doing everything we can
to make sure
that this situation is as it should be
yeah like you said jonathan not a whole
lot of information there so what else do
we know about feng shui's latest
movements and that interview that you
did with the french sports news site
well the strange thing is that the ise
was
yes the meeting will happen when clearly
it had already taken place so we can
only assume from that that he didn't
want to ruin any kind of carefully
staged choreography including that
interview with dalai keep that had been
set up already because we've known for
some time that the ifc was planning to
meet pengshui here in beijing as for lau
keep interview that took place
officials they keep had to submit their
questions in advance they had to publish
her answers for basem in a q a format so
that really doesn't leave too much room
for any context or explanation or indeed
any follow-up dw's jonathan crane in
beijing for us thank you very much